[Music]
it is the bestselling book in history no
volume ever written has been more loved
and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previous
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now here's your host from amazing
facts International Pastor Jean Ross
Hello friends how about an amazing Fact
one of history's most notable hoaxes is
the piltdown man an archaeological
deception that captivated the scientific
community for decades in 1912 Charles
Dawson claimed to have Unearthed The
elusive missing link between humans and
apes in piltown England the alleged
Discovery consisting of a humanlike
skull and an ap-like jaw were initially
celebrated as groundbreaking evidence
supporting a transitional species from
apes to humans and given the fervent
interest to find the so-called Missing
Link the piltown man was
enthusiastically received as a most
remarkable discovery of Evolution
drawings of the aplike human were
published in newspapers around the world
the skull was placed on display in a mum
and even a statue was made of the
piltown
man however in the 1950s advances in
dating techniques and a more
comprehensive analysis revealed that the
piltown man was nothing but a hoax the
skull belonged to human while the
Jawbone was from an orangutang both were
artificially stained to look very old
this this great hoax shows the length
that some people will go to bolster a
theory that lacks credible evidence the
Bible reminds us in Proverbs 14:15 that
the simple believe anything but the
prudent give thought to their steps this
verse teaches us that whether we're
dealing with science religion morality
or any other belief it is critical to
seek guidance from the Bible in a world
full of false ideas and misleading
philosophies turning to God's word is
like a strong sheep that protects us
against the devil's many deceptions you
know Pastor Carlos when you read about
these hoaxes of so-called discoveries
that boister some kind of theory or
evolutionary idea and then later on it's
discovered that it's uh really not doing
any of that yeah it kind of points to a
created God just like the Bible says
yeah well and especially as the uh
technology advances the instruments are
so precise now that they come across and
science is discovering that the theory
of evolution is more and more
discredited right and archaeologically
too confirming the what the Bible says
historically and and scientifically so
we say praise God for that amen
absolutely and of course intelligent
design the more they study the cell and
the smaller little uh way the cell
interacts it's just evidence that
somebody designed all of this yes you
know we do have a free offer it's called
when Evolution flunked the science test
Maybe you're wondering about you know
what does the Bible say about the fact
that God created us but then how do we
refute these ideas about Evolution and
uh well it's in the book it'll tell you
more about it if you'd like to receive
the book just call and ask what number
do they call for that yeah they call
1800 835
6747 and ask for offer number
169 and so also if you're in the US you
can dial
2550 and when you dial number 2550 you
can say say Bible answers live and ask
for that free offer when Evolution
flunked the science T that's the name of
the free offer yes we have free shipping
in the US US territories and Canada only
and we also wanted to take a second to
greet the listeners from kpls in Denver
and KTP J in peblo Colorado that are
joining us all right and greetings to
those who are joining us new to uh Bible
answers live well before we go to the
phone lines why don't we start with a
word of prayer sure let's pray father
thank you again for this beautiful day
and this beautiful opportunity to spend
time in your word I ask that you just
give us wisdom and discernment and also
bless those that are listening and
calling so that we can have a just a
lively discussion and that your name may
be glorified in all things we ask this
in Jesus name amen amen all right number
one we have uh Jerry from Texas calling
us Jerry welcome you are live hey hey
guys I got a long question here uh my
question refers to Revelation 20: 7 and9
how long will this Rebellion last for
the long failed D Day Invasion at the
door of the New Jerusalem one religious
author indicates Satan will be develop
weapons of war for the onslaught of
God's people one time Doug mentioned
more than maybe 20 years what are your
thoughts today all right well good
question let me read the verse for those
who might be traveling and and uh
they're not familiar with the passage
Revelation chapter 20 in verse 7
starting verse 7 it says now when the
thousand years were expired Satan will
be released from his prison and he will
go out and deceive the Nations which are
on the four corners of the earth Gog and
Magog to gather them together to battle
whose number is as the sand of the sea
and they went up the breadth of the
earth and they surrounded the camp of
the Saints the Beloved City and fire
came down from God out of heaven and
devoured them so just a little bit of
the background here we're talking about
the 1,000-year period known as the
Millennium we read about in Revelation
chapter 20 the beginning of the
Millennium is the second coming of
Christ so Jesus comes the second time
the dead in Christ are resurrected the
living righteous are changed in a moment
in the twinkling of an eye and together
they are caught up to meet Jesus in the
air the wicked are destroyed with the
brightness of Christ coming but the
redeemed go to heaven and they there for
a thousand years in heaven with Christ
the devil is bound to this earth
described as the bottomless pit for this
thousand years but at the end of the
Thousand Years the New Jerusalem the
redeemed and Christ and God in heaven
moves down to this earth you read about
the Revelation chap 21 where John says I
saw the New Jerusalem descending from
God out of heaven and it's at that point
that the wicked are then resurrected for
the great white Throne judgment that we
read about here in Revelation chapter 20
at the end of the great white Throne
judgment according to these verses the
devil goes out and he's able to deceive
the wicked and it describes them as the
sand of the sea and they mount their
attack upon the New Jerusalem the Golden
City and then fire comes down and
devours them so the question is asked
how long after the resurrection of um
well how long after the New Jerusalem
comes down at the end of the Thousand
Years and the resurrection of the wicked
and the Great White Throne judgment to
when Satan and the wicked are destroyed
now of course the Bible does not say but
there is quite a few things that have to
happen after the resurrection of the
wicked you got this final Judgment at
the end of which the Bible says every
knee bows and every tongue confesses
that Jesus is Lord and that God is fair
and that he's done everything to save
mankind it's not a confession of guilt
or a recognition of of sin rather it's
just an acknowledgement of the evidence
because no sooner do they do that when
they actually Mount this attack upon the
New Jerusalem so you know the Bible
doesn't say it could be months it could
be
years uh we don't know we'll have to
wait and see yeah matter of fact the
Bible says the devil will be loosed
after his prison for a little season
that's the actual wording that we find
there in Revelation loose for a little
season so whatever that little season is
uh the Bible doesn't say yeah it's
important as that we're on the right
side that's right we want to be inside
the New Jerusalem amen when that time
comes well hopefully that helps Jerry
who do we have next next we have Axel
from Pennsylvania I'm thinking Axel
welcome to Bible answers live you're on
the air how you doing Pastor doing well
nice to meet you my question is so Adam
and Eve was the first humans then it was
Cain and Abel and I believe Cain was the
one killed Abel right correct but C
killed Abel okay I I'm not sure if I
mixed up to names so that's why I asked
so my other question is why did he say
why did God send them to a city a city
or was a city right well not at first I
mean after um Adam and Eve were driven
from the Garden of Eden it says that
they had two sons and they also had
other Sons and Daughters the Bible says
but um Cain killed able and yeah as as
the population grew uh eventually you
know hundreds of years they lived 900
years before the flood so the population
grew and as time went on uh cities were
were put together or came together so it
didn't happen immediately after Adam and
Eve were banished from the garden but
sometime after that oh okay okay cuz I
wasn't sure cuz he he was worried about
him he was worried about people killing
him and I thought I was like people
killing him there only wasn't there the
only four humans how and God said there
were other the siblings so he was
worried about his siblings doing him in
so that's why he he complained about
that okay that makes sense that makes
sense yeah all right well good question
thank you for for calling Axel thank you
very much Axel next we have Eva from
Oklahoma you are on the air IBA
welcome yes uh I am concerned about um
the position that uh we that advent is
whole on the Feast of the Jews is it for
Jewish people are uh like you know the
Feast of Tabernacles the Feast of
trumpets and uh all these different
things that I thought was for was
because Jesus had brought the Jews out
of Egypt and and uh that they had
U they had been disobedient and and so
Moes Moses had to write some things that
the Lord told it so are are you
wondering do we still have to keep the
feast days today yes in in this period
of time yeah that's a good question
that's a good question well what we need
to understand that when we get into the
Old Testament we see different groupings
of law uh there are at least four types
of law that we read about in the Old
Testament the most important law of
course is the moral law otherwise known
as the Ten Commandments uh transgression
of the Ten Commandments is sin the Bible
says sin is the transgression of the law
so that's the Ten Commandments uh Adam
and Eve broke the Ten Commandments and
that's where sin came in to the whole
your human race and Earth and the Ten
Commandment has always been and of
course that's that needs to be kept even
today Revelation 12:17 talks about those
that keep the Commandments of God and
have the faith of Jesus but in addition
to the Ten Commandment law there were
also certain Health laws that God
instructed the Israelites to follow but
the health laws preceded the Israelites
because you read when came to the time
of the flood and God told Noah to take
into the ark clean and unclean animals
they were aware there was a distinction
made between the clean and the unclean
and the sacrificial system which was
implemented right after Adam and Eve
sinned they were driven from the garden
only clean animals could be sacrificed
so there was a distinction between clean
unclean animals and some of the other
health laws associated with that uh that
even predated Abraham but then when the
children of Israel were brought out of
Egypt God gave them some add additional
laws and that's kind of where the feast
days fall in it's what we call the
ceremonial laws it's connected with the
sanctuary service God told Moses to
build a sanctuary it involved the
levitical priesthood and there were
certain feast days that pointed to the
coming of the Messiah just like the lamb
pointed to Jesus who would come and die
so the feast days not only pointed to
the coming of the Messiah but it also
reminded the Jews of their deliverance
from slavery in Egypt for example the
Passover so it had a purpose of looking
forward to the coming of the Messiah but
also for the nation helping to remind
them that God was the one that led them
up out of Egypt uh there are principles
connected with the feast days that I
think is interesting for us to study but
we cannot keep the feast days today the
why the way the Bible commands the Bible
required that everyone was to go to
Jerusalem for the feast or go up to the
sanctuary and they were to offer
sacrifices on the feast well of course
we don't offer sacrifices today we don't
have journey to Jerusalem um so so it
doesn't apply to Christians today Jesus
is our Passover he is the land that was
slain for us since and then the final
category are the Civil laws that govern
the nation of Israel now some of those
principles are still you know valuable
for Nations today but we're not under
theocracy the way the Jews were when God
LED them up out of the land of Egypt so
uh some of those aspects don't apply now
either but probably the most important
thing for us to recognize is that the
Ten Commandment law or the moral law is
always binding it has been binding and
uh it'll be kept even in you Earth made
new amen I think one of the most
beautiful things of the feast days is
that it's a prophetic calendar and it
shows how each stage of the way a
different phase of how Christ is saving
us yes and so we're now in the day of
atonement and so we're just waiting for
the end of the day of atonement for what
as we read in Revelation 21 Tabernacles
when we're in the presence of God so you
know you bring up a good point the Bible
talks about this day of atonement that
occurred once a year on the day of
atonement for the Jewish people but but
we're living in that antitypical day of
atonement which isn't just one day but
it's ongoing right now as you read about
in Daniel chapter 7 some other places in
the Bible so some interesting parallels
there that we can see all right well
hopefully that helps I think we have a
book called feast days and sabbaths and
we'll be happy to send that to uh anyone
who would like to get more information
on that so just go ahead and um call and
ask for that feast days and sabbaths
yeah they can text also number 250
number 250 in the US and when you call
here Bible answers live and ask for that
for that free gift also uh let's go next
with uh Britany from here in California
hello Britney you're welcome to Bible
answers live hey hi Britney and your
question today my question is did
Rahab s when he saved the Israelites
from their enemies and Joshua too by
lying okay well um you know the Bible
says that sin is the transgression of
the law and did she lie yes she did but
the Bible also tells us that at our
times of ignorance God Winks at in other
words we're judged based on what we know
she grew up in a pagan Nation she was
not fully aware of all of The
Commandments she did what she thought
was right in that case to try and
protect um the spies and God recognized
her faith and God honored that faith and
she and her household was saved but I'm
sure once she you know got connected
with the nation of Israel and learned
more about the religion of the Jews and
had a clear understanding of God's
requirements his law I'm sure did she
didn't continue lying after that so um
at the time you God even though it was
sin God judged her or God judges each
person based on what they KN they know
and she was sort of living up to
everything she knew at that time yeah
she was a prostitute too and so we know
she had a difficult life before that too
yeah her life was changed and you know
the amazing thing about Rahab is you
read later on where he talks about the
in the chapter The Heroes of Faith Rahab
he's mentioned but then also she's in
the lineage of well eventually David and
Jesus amen so just a remarkable story
amen amen thank you very much Britney
next we have Debbie calling us from
Canada you're on the air sister Debbie
welcome Hi how are you you're doing good
okay I have a question about tattoos I
know what it says about tattooing your
skin in the Bible but did God ever tell
somebody to get a
tattoo did God ever tell somebody to get
a tattoo well there is one reference
which kind of interesting uh it was back
in in the Jewish economy if somebody was
a slave or they had given them
themselves into slavery for a period of
time and the time came for their release
they could choose if they wanted to
remain a slave if they Lov their master
and they were sort of adopted as part of
the family there was a practice that
occurred where the ear was driven
through as a the piercing of the ear as
a sign that um you know the slave was
indebted forever to be with his master
and I think there was uh a possibility
of a marking at that point as well but
that's the only instance that that we
read about uh that was a very unique
situation that's not tattoos in general
for sure the Bible tells us not to get a
tattoo now having said that that's not
the unpardonable sin there probably many
people that have got tattoos and they
realize yeah you know they come to a
knowledge the truth and uh that doesn't
mean by by any means that that God can't
forgive but if you know the will of God
well you don't want to go out and get
another tattoo right going to ask for
forgiveness and move on with your life
so um that's the only instance I can
think of Debbie does does that help a
little yes it does thank you so much all
right thanks you Cole who do we have
next next we have Gary calling from
Illinois welcome to Bible answers live
Gary thank you I have a hard time
understanding Christ Jesus as Michael
the Archangel so in Jude chter 1 ver9 it
says Yet Michael the Archangel in
contending with the devil when he
disputed about the body of Moses dared
not bring against him reviling
accusation but said to him uh th the
Lord rebuke you so why would the creator
of the universe dare not to bring
reviling accusation against Lucifer okay
good question well first of all Let me
give a little bit of a background and
then we can specifically talk about that
verse so in the Bible we read about this
this being called Michael and he's
referred to in Jude as the Archangel but
you also read about in Revelation 12
where it says there was war in heaven
Michael and his angels fought against
the dragon and his angels and the dragon
lost and he was cast out of heaven we
also read in the Book of Daniel it
refers to Michael the great prince who
stands on behalf of thy people in Daniel
chter 12 and then when it's talking
about the second coming of Christ Jesus
Jesus said the time is coming that those
who are in their grave will hear his
voice that is the voice of the son of
man and they shall come forth and then
Thessalonian says that when the Lord
comes he comes with the Shout with the
voice of the Archangel and the trumpet
of God and the dead in Christ rise first
so the voice that raises the dead
according to Thessalonians is the voice
of the Archangel and Jesus says it's my
voice that raises the dead and Michael
is referred to the great prince who
stands on behalf of his people what
Jesus stands on behalf of his people the
war that occurred in in Revelation 12
between Michael and his angels was a war
between Christ and his angels and the
devil and those angels that sighted with
him so what's confusing people is the
name Archangel does that mean that Jesus
is an angel a created being like all the
other Angels the answer is no the word
there Archangel simply means the one
above or the ruler or the commander of
the Angels just like an arch is above
something so the commander of the Angels
the one in charge of the Angels is
Michael Michael is the prophetic name of
Jesus that we find there in Daniel and
Jude as well as in Revelation now an
angel in Bible prophecy in its strict
sense if you look up the Greek it means
messenger it's angalo it simply means
messenger and not only do we have
Angelic beings referred to as Angels but
even people are referred to angels as
you read in Revelation Chapter 2 and 3
and Revelation chapter 14 talks about
the Three Angels messages it really is
description of God's people taking this
end time message to the world so an
angel is a messenger and there were
times in the Old Testament where Jesus
came bringing a message he's referred to
as the angel of the Lord the messenger
the Lord now when Jesus was talking to
the devil in the case of resurrecting
Moses when Christ was tempted in the
wilderness by the devil Jesus didn't get
into an argument with the devil he just
simply quoted scripture likewise when he
came to resurrect Moses and the devil
was protesting say well you can't
resurrect him Jesus didn't get into a
dispute or an argument he just said the
Lord rebukes you so uh there's no need
to get in argument with the devil it's
pretty evident to all the angels in the
universe um you know who's right and
who's wrong and so God rebuked the devil
and Moses was resurrected and we know
that he was resurrected because he
appeared later on uh with Elijah and
Jesus on the Mount of transfiguration
you know we do have a book it's called
who is Michael the Archangel after that
long explanation there's a whole lot
more in the book with all the Bible
verses and we'll be happy to send it to
anyone who calls and asks just call and
ask who is Michael the Archangel 1 1800
6747 thank you very much Gary next we
have Glenn from Ohio welcome Glenn
you're on the
air thank you good let me first of all
say that your ministry is quite or your
your program is quite a Ministry and I
appreciate that amen well thank you
thank you for taking my call glad to do
it my call concerns the abomination of
desolation as spoken of by the Prophet
Daniel yes I understand it's a big End
Time Event uh can you help me understand
what is the abomination of desolation
who performs when and where all right
good question there are actually two
parts to the abomination of desolation
if you look in Matthew Jesus talking
about uh the destruction of Jerusalem
says when you see the abomination of
desolation spoken of by Daniel the
prophet stand in the Holy place then let
him that be in Judea flee into the
mountains so in the immediate sense the
abomination of desolation was the Roman
armies that came and surrounded
Jerusalem in 70 AD and brought about its
downfall now uh history tells us that
the Christians heeded that warning given
by Christ and they were able to Escape
From the City of Jerusalem and no
Christians were killed in the
destruction of Jerusalem in 70 AD uh the
same Passage is translating in Luke and
he says when you see armies surrounding
Jerusalem then know that its desolation
is nigh then let him that be in Juda
flee into the mountains you might even
have that verse there Pastor Carlos so
uh we understand the abomination of
desolation first in its in its first
application represents um Pagan roome
but there's also a second phase we call
that papal roome and there is a
Resurgence of papal power in the last
days and we can actually see that
happening in the world around us today
uh the popularity of the papacy its
influence both in not only religious
things but also political things a time
will come where certain laws will be
promoted and passed that restrict
religious worship or religious freedom
actually contradicting one of God's
Commandments that will be to God's
people a clear sign that another
abomination of desolation is being set
up so that is the Dual or secondary
application of what the abomination of
desolation is do you have anything else
you want to add to that Matthew
24:15
forward the Abomination desolation yep
okay very good well thank you for your
call um who do we have next next we have
Dwayne calling us from Georgia welcome
to Bible answers live Dwayne you're on
the
air hey thank you Carlos I appreciate
your uh your time and your ministry
gentlemen and taking my call sure uh my
fir my question has to do with actually
a lot with what you guys hit right right
throughout the the very first question
the first caller uh with Revelations 20:
8 and N yes I've always been curious is
that why would Satan attempt to attack
the Beloved city of God here at the end
knowing he's already lost the battle why
why would he want to do this is it is it
possible that he wants to get inside
hopefully last ditch effort maybe to get
to the tree of life or I mean why is why
is he doing this yeah you know that's a
good why is he going to do it yeah
that's a good question I mean you think
that he's read the Bible he should know
the way the story ends but remember this
being wants worship more than anything
else he wanted to receive the worship
that only belongs to God he wanted to be
as the most high in heaven before he was
cast out of Heaven perhaps and the Bible
doesn't say but perhaps the devil seeing
the vast numbers on his side standing
outside the city uh somehow is able to
think that with overwhelming um Power or
or numbers he might be able to conquer
the city really he wants to take God
from his throne he wants to uh Rule and
perhaps he realizes sort of a suicide
mission and he's going to take everybody
down with him at the time but he's able
to convince them to actually Mount this
attack upon the New Jerusalem and uh you
can't attack God I mean God created all
things and you wonder why would even
think that but you know sin does that to
a person causes people to do some very
foolish things I mean look at our world
look at what sin has caused people to do
so um I think Satan has been so
connected to sin and self that
perhaps he even deceives himself at
least he's able to deceive the people to
thinking that he's going to be
victorious maybe he's able to convince
himself that he thinks he's going to be
victorious but the Bible makes it clear
that there's no hope uh God will cleanse
the Earth from sin and sinners the fire
that destroys the devil and his angels
is the fire that purifies the Earth and
then God creates a new heavens and a new
Earth wherein dwells righteousness well
friends we're coming up on our mid
program break so don't go very far away
we're going to be right back with more
of your Bible questions
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return
[Music]
shortly Doug Bachelor was the teenage
son of a millionaire father and show
business mother yet he was living in a
cave he had everything money could buy
everything but happiness but all of the
fun and excitement he enjoyed left his
life out of control his search
eventually led him to a cave above of
Palm Springs that became his home while
Dougs scavenged for food and garbage
bins his father owned a yacht a Learjet
and an airline but in his cave home he
discovered a dust covered Bible as he
began to read he soon learned of his
true purpose in life the richest caveman
is the extraordinary true story of Doug
Bachelor that tells how a rebellious
teenager who once lived in a cave became
a tremendous Soul winner for Jesus
Christ it's a thrilling test of the
transforming power of God's word to
order your copy of the richest caveman
call
85387 275 or visit AF bookstore.com did
you know amazing fact has a free Bible
school that you can do from the comfort
of your own home it includes 27
beautifully Illustrated study lessons to
Aid in your study of God's word sign up
today for this free Bible study course
by calling 1844 215 7000 that's 18 844
7000 every year 40,000 souls in North
America end their own lives suicide is a
terrible tragedy and while it's
difficult to talk about we need to face
it together as Christians that's why in
my new book choosing life I share the
biblical perspective about suicide
answering some difficult questions about
faith and salvation along the way and
offering practical tips that should help
and encourage others Jesus wants us to
choose an abundant life in
him go into all the world and preach the
gospel to Every Creature through radio
television print Evangelistic events and
the internet amazing facts International
is heeding the call of Jesus to go into
all the world millions of individuals in
over 150 countries have been blessed by
the word of God amazing facts has
spawned new spheres of influence in
India Africa China and Indonesia with
each new country come hundreds of
translated booklets study guides and
video presentations produced in each
region for the people of that region
armed with these precious truths gospel
workers are empowered to spread bright
rays of light on every path they travel
please visit reachthe world.
amazingfacts.org to learn more about
amazing facts International and how you
can participate in this exciting
soul-winning Ministry that website again
is the world. amazingfacts.org thank you
for your
[Music]
support you're listening to Bible
answers live where every question
answered provides a clearer picture of
God and his plan to save you so what are
you waiting for get practical answers
about the good book for a better life
today this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode if you'd like answers
to your Bible related questions on the
air please call us next Sunday between
7:00 p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific time to
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800 835
6747 once again that's 800 835
6747 now let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible answers
live Hello friends you're listening to
Bible answers live a live in active
International Bible study I'd like to
welcome all of those who might have
joined us halfway through the program
and as mentioned if you have a Bible
question we'd love to hear from you
tonight just give us a call the number
is 800
46372 N7 that'll bring you in here to
our studio if we don't answer your call
right away just stay uh stand by and we
will get to your uh question your your
telephone call as soon as possible my
name is John Ross Carlos Munos that's
right and we're ready to go to the phone
lines who do we have next next we have
Lynn from the state of Oregon welcome to
Bible answers live Lynn hello yes my
questions about Leviticus
1919 and Deuteronomy
[Music]
221 in Leviticus
1919 says you shall keep my statutes you
shall not let your livestock breed with
another kind you shall not sew your
field with mixed
seed nor shall a garment of mixed linen
and wool come upon
you and uh Deuteronomy
says you shall not wear a garment of
different sorts such as wool and linen
mixed together now when I took history
class and they said that the
colonists a lot of the garments that
they wore were of a M Fabric they called
lindsy woy which is just that linen and
wool mixed
together and many of our garments today
are of all kinds of combinations of
different
materials okay so you're wondering why
did God make this law for the Jews or
are you wondering is it wrong for us to
wear clothing that is mixed Fabrics yeah
is it wrong for us to wear clothing with
mixed fabric all right good question
well first of all no it's not wrong for
us to wear Fabrics of mixed clothing
because if we read on in that same
passage verse 12 in Deuteronomy 22 it
says you shall make tassels on the four
corners of your clothing so here not
only is it telling the Israelites not to
wear clothing of mixed Fabrics but it
says you also need to make these tassels
that you wear at the borders of your
garments this is part of the ceremonial
law that God gave to the nation of
Israel you see God wanted them to be
distinct and separate from the Nations
that surrounded them the tassels on the
Hem of their garment was to remind them
that they were a holy people and remind
them of obedience to God's law and so
they were practical aspects of not
mixing linen and wool and different
Fabrics just like there's practical
aspects of not uh using mixed seed when
you sew your
Fields so there was some practical
aspects but I think it it extended even
more than that uh garments in the Bible
uh represent the righteousness or
character and of course the Bible speaks
about the Redeemed clothed in a white
robe representing Christ's righteousness
that they would receive uh the carment
of the priests were to be pure they
weren't to be of mixed Fabrics it was a
type a shadow Israel is a holy people a
holy nation were to be set apart now
there are practical aspects of that for
our day today I think a Christian is to
dress a little differently from the
world we are to dress modestly uh we are
to dress neatly cleanly there should be
a distinction in dress between the
Christian and the non-Christian but it's
not referring to us not being able to
wear clothing of mixed Fabrics that had
to do more specifically with the nation
of Israel does that help uh Lynn yes
that does okay great well thank you for
your call next we have Christopher here
from California you are live on the air
Christopher hello hello thank you for
taking my call uh my question is um is
it a sin to celebrate uh birthdays is it
a sin to celebrate birthdays no it's
it's not a sin now there might be some
celebrations that people do
that might be sinful but not you know
just celebrating a birthday is not a sin
in and of itself but if somebody has a a
big party and there alcohol and music
and dancing well yeah that could that
could be a sinful thing but just
recognizing somebody's birth day uh
there's nothing wrong with that okay so
like receiving gifts from family members
is it's okay y absolutely you know if it
doesn't contradict the law of God it's
okay and you know in our culture today
we have many different Customs that
don't contradict the word of God for
example Thanksgiving uh there's nothing
wrong in celebrating Thanksgiving or
spending time with family so yeah a
birthday falls into that same category
it's not a contradiction of a
commandment okay well that's it then
thank you all right thanks Christopher
thanks next next we have Shan from
Michigan welcome to Bible answers line
Sean you're on the
air thank you for taking my call I'm
calling in the third time that I've
called you guys so um this is from Ruth
4:7 U comparing with Mark 1 ver7 so I'll
read it here from the King James version
Ruth 4:7 now this was the manner in
former time in Israel concerning
redeeming and concerning changing or to
confirm all things a man plucked off his
shoe and gave it to his neighbor and
this is a testimony in Israel I'll pause
there uh the context of this is about uh
the Kinsman that ends up not redeeming
um
the inherit like basically the the uh
land that would be associated with Ruth
the moias because her husband had died
and Naomi's husband died ends up going
to to Boaz um and I wasn't sure if
because he chooses to do that in Mark 1
ver7 it says and preach saying there
cometh one mightier than I after me the
latchet who shoes I'm not worthy to
stoop down and un loose my question is
whether this whole thing about taking
off the shoe um the the thing about the
shoe in Ruth 47 and Mark 17 is there any
connection is John the Baptist alluding
to that about like not being honorable
enough to do something for Jesus that's
a good connection yeah yeah that's an
interesting connection well first of all
when it talks about take your shoes off
take your sandals off that is a
reference first and foremost of
recognizing that you're in the presence
of someone important when Moses was
approaching the burning bush God called
out from the burning bush and said Moses
take the sandals off your feet
the place where you're standing is Holy
Ground And when John is referring to
Jesus and he says I'm unworthy to to bow
down and even you know loose his sandals
it's a reference to the fact that Christ
is Holy the Bible speaks of him as being
that Holy thing with reference to the
announcement of his birth so that's the
first sense that John is referring to
when he talks about the sandal uh also
in the Middle East culture um it was
interesting even today I travel to India
and um as a sign of reverence or respect
when you go into a church you remove
your shoes you go in Barefoot and that
was also a custom even back then in the
time of Israel and I think that because
of that that custom associated with
giving a sandal had to do something
along with a covenant now there were
different types of rituals connected
with covenants in the Bible you read the
story where uh another Covenant was
where you place your hand under uh the
thigh when when Abraham was getting a
son um for Jacob he had his servant
place his hand under his thigh and make
an oath so that's also another form that
had changed it seems at least by the
time of Ruth and the custom at that time
was just exchanging a sandal as part of
an official contract that was being made
so the connection with John it's
interesting i' never seen that before
specifically as relates here but I think
John is referring to the fact that Jesus
is Holy and that's why he was not worthy
to Lucy sand
yes thank you Sean next we have Robert
from Washington welcome to Bible answers
live good to be here um thank you Pastor
Ross Pastor Munos he what's your
question brother uh Acts 3
19-21 it talks about a restoration there
or a
restoring um and I I always thought that
that it was supposed to be uh restoring
when Jesus comes but maybe I'm wrong
okay well let me read the verses for
those who might be listening uh Acts
chapter 3 beginning verse 19 it says
repent therefore and be converted that
your sins might be blotted out so that
the time of refreshing may come from the
presence of the Lord and that he will
send or may send Jesus Christ who was
preached to you before whom Heaven Must
receive until the times of restoration
of all things which God has spoken by
the mouth of all of his holy prophets
since the world began so is your
question about the phrase it says until
the restoration of all things correct
yeah I just um like like I said I always
thought that had to do with when Jesus
comes but maybe maybe I I'm wrong well
no it's definitely referring to uh the
second coming of Christ because it says
in verse 20 and that he may send Jesus
Christ who was preached to you before
whom Heaven Must receive which where
that's what Jesus is now whom Heaven
Must receive until the times of
restoration of all things so here it's
talking about a time of restoration now
when it's talking about restoration it's
talking about a restoration of the
truths all of the truths of scripture
and if you look historically after the
legalization of Christianity in 3:13
there were a number of strange Pagan
ideas and Concepts that came into the
Christian Church some of those um were
contradicted during the time of the
Reformation but even into the 1800s
there were still some misunderstandings
about what the Bible teaches a number of
important teachings and doctrines but
here the promise is given before Jesus
comes there will be a full restoration
of Truth God will have a people who love
him keep his Commandments they have the
faith of Jesus and the truth that was
preached through the prophets all of the
truth will be made manifest in the last
days and we also see this uh Illustrated
in Revelation 18 18 ver1 where it says
John saw an angel coming down from
heaven and the Earth was illuminated
with his glory and he cried mightily
with a strong voice and you see the
Angels messages proclaiming God's three
uh aspects of his last warning message
to the world so that's referring to this
Proclamation this restoration of the
truths of God's word yeah and then Jesus
comes which falls right into that
prophetic time frame yeah in Matthew
chapter 17 verse 11 it says Elijah is
coming to restore all things that's
right a special outpouring of the holy
spirit is the Days of Elijah so does
that help Robert yeah so the the
doctrines the truth of of God's word are
are restored first and then Jesus comes
that's right there is a there is a group
of people that are sealed according to
Revelation chapter 7 before Jesus comes
so uh part of that ceiling is a
restoration of of all the truths of
God's
word all right thank you all right great
question thanks for calling thank you
Robert next we have Lee from North
Carolina Welcome to Bible answers live
Lee you're on the air thank you so much
for taking my call pastors my question
is regarding Deuteronomy chapter 14 God
talks about the unclean foods do not eat
This Not That and then Mark chapter 7 um
verses 18 and 19 when Jesus um is
explaining it I think in a parable and
then the disciples afterwards say you
know Lord what did you mean exactly and
um he says well I can't believe he
didn't understand but whatever enters a
man from the outside doesn't defile him
because it's eliminated by the stomach
and then he says thus purifying the food
yes and so I'm confused I know that you
know this is God both times is God's
word and I'm just could you shine some
light on that yeah great question all
right uh first of all if you read the
context well Deuteronomy there's a clear
distinction May between clean and
unclean animals not only is that with
reference to eating meaning that God
told his people and I believe it's true
today if you're going to eat meat you
only want to eat the clean animals it
was also important for the sacrificial
system that is distinction be made
between clean and unclean animals but
then in the context here if you read in
Mark chapter 7 there was a dispute that
arose because the disciples did not wash
their hands before they ate and it was
the religious leaders that had created
all kinds of traditions associated with
everything and one of the Traditions
they had is that there was a certain
type of ceremonial washing of the hands
and the washing of bowls and cups and
plates and all kinds of things
associated with uh eating and the
disciples they were on the road they
were traveling and they were hungry and
they ate they didn't do that ceremonial
washing with their hands and this caused
a bit of controversy and of course the
religious leaders brought that up to to
the disciples and to Jesus and then
Jesus said it's not that which goes into
a man that defiles him but it's that
which comes out of the man um when Jesus
says it's not that which goes into the
man he's not making a statement on you
can eat anything you want because that
wouldn't make sense obviously we can eat
things that damage the body Jesus would
say you can eat things that damage the
body because the Bible says our bodies
are the Temple of the Holy Spirit he
will destroy those that destroy the body
so he's not saying that you can just eat
whatever you want or whatever you know
crawls across your plate some of the
things are harmful you don't want to eat
it but he's specifically addressing the
tradition of washing of the hands Jesus
says don't worry about that that's not
the most important thing the most
important thing is what comes out of the
man meaning out of the heart now they
connected the washing of the hands with
spiritual defilement if you didn't wash
your hands you would been spiritually
defiled Jesus says no that's got nothing
to do with spiritual defilement
spiritual defilement is that which comes
from the heart it comes from the inside
it comes out so that's the context and
again you need to always read read this
in its context you mentioned the phrase
thus purifying all foods it's also
interesting that uh the word thus is
actually added it's not part of the
original manuscripts it was added by the
translators for for cl it so that's not
the original text just simply Jesus is
saying it's not what goes into the man
that brings spiritual defilement but
it's that which comes out of a man which
brings spiritual defilement that's the
point that he's making and Matthew 15 is
a little bit more clearer than Mark when
it says in Matthew 15:20 these things
which defile a man but to eat with
unwashed hands defiles not a man so
that's the clarification clarification
in Matthew 15 so it's always good to
look the parallel ver that's a great
Point very good point all right
hopefully that helps Lee who do we have
like next next we have Lisa from Florida
Welcome Lisa first time how are you
doing I'm doing well thank you guys um
Pastor Ross and Pastor Munos my question
has to do with um the Israelites the
plague with the Egyptian was that within
a span of a year and if so is that what
we are to expect um for the plate seen
in
Revelation okay good question well the
the first distinction that we have
between the plagues that fell upon Egypt
and the ones that fell upon or described
as falling in Revelation is that there
were 10 plagues that Came Upon Egypt and
Revelation speaks about seven plagues
the seven last plagues that come on the
earth after probation closes before
Jesus comes uh the distinction between
that is the first three plagues affected
not only the is the Egyptians but it
also to some degree affected the
Israelites but the seven last plagues
after that only affected the Egyptians
it did not affect the Israelites they
were protected meaning that when the
seven last plagues are poured out upon
the Earth God will protect his people
these are judgments that come upon the
wicked now how long did it take for
those plagues those 10 plagues to fall
upon Egypt it was less than a year
because there was some rapid uh events
taking place uh there was also terrible
devastation that occurred and it would
have probably caused a lot of harm if
people tried to continue for an extended
period of time under those conditions so
it probably occurred within a matter of
months now the seven last plagues um
fall within a year I think there's good
evidence in the Bible to suggest that
because Revelation speaks about the
plagues coming upon a power called
Babylon and says her plague shall come
in one day one prophetic day in the
Bible is e to one literal year now of
course the plagues that Came Upon Egypt
were just for one country the seven last
plagues are for the whole world so it
takes about a year or roughly within a
period of a year for the seven last
plagues to be poured out yeah in
Revelation it talks about 16 it says the
day of the Wrath so there again thetic
principle y conect yeah does that uh
help Lisa yes thank you guys have a
great day all right thanks thank you
next we have Bobby from Washington
welcome Bobby you're on the
air hi uh my sister and I have a
difference of opinion about when Christ
will come back uh I my thought was that
uh the the righteous will go up in into
the air and meet those that are risen
that have passed on that and are
resurrected um and that the evil will
that the
Dead uh Evil Dead people will stay in
their graves and those that are evil and
living will die my sister says or she
believes that God is God of love and
would
not kill his people or his creation okay
I tell her that it's a a a a punishment
or a judgment of how they've either
rejected or accepted Christ um and at
the end of the Millennium when Christ
returns and um the evil people that have
that were dead are resurrected and uh at
that time those people will die in a a
Lake of Fire that was created for the
devil MH and she doesn't believe she
thinks that
um that we would when God withdraws his
spirit that you can't live without his
presence and that's why they die they
just kind of fall over and they're
they're gone sure but I believe that
they would share in the punishment with
with the Satan and his angels yeah let
me give you a few thoughts that might
add to that you know it's true that um
God takes no no Delight in the death of
the wicked the Bible says that there's
no pleasure God takes no Delight he says
therefore repent and turn why will you
die the Bible says God is Not slack
concerning his promise speaking of the
second coming but his longsuffering
towards us not willing that any should
perish but that all should come to
repentance so God doesn't want anyone to
be destroyed but at the end of time
there's a couple of scenarios that we
look at first of all just before Jesus
comes there is a universal death decree
that is pronounced against the people of
God Jesus comes to the Deliverance of
his people and as he delivers his people
the wicked are destroyed with the
brightness of his coming 2 Thessalonians
2:8 says the wicked are destroyed to the
brightness of his coming and then at the
end of the thousand years we just read
in Revelation chap 20 the scenario is
that the wicked are outside the city
with the devil and his angels and they
actually mount an attack upon the New
Jerusalem and the Bible says fire comes
down and devours them so both cases it
is God coming to the deliverance and the
defense of of his people and as a result
judgment falls upon the wicked and they
are destroyed the Bible says God is a
consuming fire and for those who have
rebelled against him and are determined
to destroy his faithful people there is
nothing else God can do but put a stop
to them and that is through death and
the means that he's chosen is fire to
destroy the devil and his angels and the
wicked who have sided with him and then
he makes a new heavens and a new Earth
so God takes no pleasure in the death of
the wicked but there is a destruction
that comes upon the Wicked the Bible's
pretty clear on that if you read
Revelation and also the Old Testament
talks about a fire consuming the devil
and his angels and they'll be turned to
ashes upon upon the Earth so yeah the
Bible's pretty clear on that yeah and
it's interesting too with the flood he
destroyed the surface of the Earth with
water next time it's not going to be
with water but it's going to be with
fire you know it's interesting uh the
two symbols of water and fire water is a
symbol of baptism and fire symbol of the
holy spirit so the righteous are
cleansed by water and fire but the
Wicked the Earth is cleansed by water
and fire literal water in the time of
the flood and fire that devours the
Wicked at the end of the Thousand Years
y okay who do we all right next we have
taiw taiwana from Virginia welcome
taiwana you're on the air thank you both
for taking my call um hope you're having
a good evening my question is and I've
been listening to your sermons and
Pastor Doug Bachelor and my question is
why are some when we die we sleep
until Jesus Christ um resurrect us and
there's some people in heaven and my
cousin and I been talking and she asked
me um CU I was sharing with her what I
was learning and her question is well if
that's the case that when we die we
sleep in the grave and we know nothing
then in Ephesians
314-
15 um mainly 15 it says from whom the
whole family in Heaven and Earth is
named and then about the
trans uh
Transfiguration with Jesus Christ yeah
and who appeared with him Was Elijah and
Moses and we know Elijah in a chariot
yeah let me jump in before we run out of
time I'm looking at the clock good
question uh Elijah was taken to Heaven
Enoch was taken to heaven without dying
and Moses was resurrected and taken to
Heaven you read about that in the book
of Jude so we know Enoch uh Elijah Moses
are in heaven there was also a group
that was resurrected at the time of
Christ's resurrection and the Bible
doesn't give us their names but they
ascended with Jesus to heaven and they
are first fruits but the general
Resurrection doesn't happen until Jesus
comes the second time that's when people
uh receive their rewards so there's just
a small exception you got in before the
flood you got Enoch uh Elijah and Moses
and then this group that was resurrected
the time of Christ's Resurrection but
everyone else will be resurrected when
Jesus comes so um hopefully that helps
you know we do have a study guide that
talks about that it's called the Dead
really dead and it gets all of the Bible
verses I think it even references Moses
and Elijah and anyone wanting to learn
more about that just call and ask uh the
number to call for that is 800 83567 47
you can ask for the amazing fact study
guide It's called are the dead R dead or
you can text what's the number they text
if they want to get it pound 250 on your
mobile device and just say Bible answers
live and and then ask for that are the
Dead really dead and we'll send it out
well friends we don't have time I'm
looking at the clock we don't have time
to take uh any more calls live but stand
by we are going to be taking your email
questions that you've sent in to those
listening on satellite radio until next
week may God bless and uh call in with
your Bible questions same time same
place next week and we look forward to
seeing you
then thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California all right we want to welcome
everybody for the special section for
our online viewers email questions that
you can send to Bal questions at amazing
fax.org and so the first question Pastor
Ross is from Alita and is is it wrong to
keep the ashes of your loved ones in
your home instead of burying or
scattering them somewhere no it's not
wrong if uh you want to keep them in a
in a vase uh at home you are more than
welcome to do that as well remember when
it comes to the resurrection God's not
going to be using any leftovers from the
earth I mean you think about it uh you
have people that were burned at the
stake during the time of the reformation
and even the early days when P pagans
persecuted the Christians so when Jesus
comes and he resurrects the righteous we
get brand new Immortal bodies so it
doesn't matter if someone's cremated or
buried or if the ashes are scattered or
placed in the ground God makes new
things yes next question from Joseph why
was the serpent cursed when it was the
devil who possessed it well you know the
devil was the one that chose to possess
the serpent and it's possible that the
serpent was one of the most beautiful
creatures in the Garden of Eden before
sin came because the Bible says the
curse that came upon the serpent he's
going to go about on his belly maybe
even had wings before that but the
serpent becomes a symbol or a type of
the devil and his Rebellion it's
unfortunate but yeah that's what
happened to the serpent but the lamb
becomes a symbol of Christ and those two
symbols we see throughout scripture last
question is from David did the war in
heaven take place shortly after Jesus
Ascension to heaven after his
crucifixion that's what it seems like
the Book of Job and Satan still had
access to Heaven before the crucifixion
and doesn't th get thrown out until the
Book of Revelation well there are two
parts to the war in heaven the first is
the devil and his angels being cast out
of Heaven that occurred before the
creation of the Earth but up until the
point of crucifixion it appears as
though the devil had some degree of
access where he claimed to be the
representative of the earth and you have
reference there to job but when Jesus
died on the cross it says he's cast to
the Earth meaning that he's bound to the
Earth no longer can the devil claim to
be the representative of the Earth
because Christ is now the second Adam
Jesus is our representative in heaven so
there's the casting out of Heaven that
occurs before the creation of the earth
and then there is the casting down of
the devil that occurs at the cross
so the devil knows he has a short time
and he's going around like a roaring
lion seeking wh whom he may devour but
God will protect and provide for his
people so yes the devil is uh sort of
bound to this earth well friends again
we want to thank you for calling in
being a part of our Bible answers Live
program and as always we want to remind
you that this is h a program a Ministry
dedicated to sharing the gospel until
next week God
bless Bible answers live honest and
accurate answers to your Bible
[Music]
questions